Ok da a oprit camerele și va da primul
perfect.
Ă ă așa,
deci partea de client management care noi
o avem cumva.
Ă ă acoperă partea operațională a unui
parc auto.
*** ziceam eu cumva este gândit să se
integreze și cu partea de contabilitate,
în sensul să transfere acele lucruri
operaționale și într-un efect contabil,
dacă cumva, există o.
Cumva există partea asta de kko instalată
în cazul în care nu se vrea,
noi putem să urmărim partea de costuri.
Avem națională de costuri la nivel de
documente, adică, de exemplu,
un bon de motorin un aer ca o amendă.
Dacă se ia,
de exemplu pe șofer și pe mașină sau dacă
există daune casco rca Uri,
dacă cumva devize de reparații care poate
să fie deviza interne de vize din service
uri terțe ă,
există inclusiv partea de contracte.
*** aveți de leasing în care poți să
vinzi specifică valoarea contractului de
leasing să văd cam ce?
Care este stadiul acelui contract?
Ă ă perfect și.
Mai mult de atat se poate întreține,
de exemplu,
flote de mașini care se poate ocupa mai
multe mașini,
prea multe subcategorii de flote.
Puteți să rețineți inclusiv șoferii care
șofer poate să fie conclusiv cu
documentele lor,
*** mai ales dacă vezi camioane sau așa
ceva.
Ei au atestate care expiră o dată la un
an 2 și în general,
dacă uită să și le reînnoiască,
atunci sunt probleme în trafic,
inclusiv permisul buletinul pe orice
poate fi urmărit cu dată de expirare.
Ă ă exist ă parte de planificare service
uri,
unde puteți să vă planificați serviciul
preventivă mentenanță care să facă
periodic la kilometri sau ore de
funcționare dacă aveți echipamente?
El la rândul lui,
fiecare etapă de mentenanță care poate fi
subcategorii gen Operații,
*** schimbul de ulei, schimbul de filtre,
nu știu anvelope care să se schimbe la un
anumit set de număr de kilometri prin
care el să creeze practic o listă de to
do se numește în carisma.
Faci un to do list în care zicea că în
următoarea săptămână sau în următoarea
imediat perioadă trebuie să faci
următoarele elemente care se apropie de
scadență.
Așa și un alt lucru care mai acoperim
este partea de comandă,
service în care pot să fac să urmăresc
devizele de reparații la nivel de linie
de reparație în care pot sa semnez,
inclusiv forța de muncă.
Adică dacă de exemplu aveți echipe de
mecanici care fiecare are un salariu pe
oră sau un anumit procent din salariul
care trăiesc în reparație,
respectiv trebuie să-i spuneți că dacă
omul ăsta lucrează 8 ore pe acel
operațiune, de fapt,
operațiunea costă atât.
Interp.
A nu e cazul că nu avem mecanici proprii,
folosim firmele autorizate pentru
Idei da deci avem și noțiunea asta în
care să fie și atelier propriu.
reparații.
Asta ideea ă ă inclusiv partea de piese,
se poate pune și ce piese trebuie,
de exemplu, la o operație de mentenanță,
după să specifici că trebuie să folosești
un anumit tip de ulei,
un anumit tip de piesă în care cumva să
te ajute și să îți dai seama cam ce
trebuie să ai în stoc înainte să te apuci
să vină partea de mentenanță.
Se poate pune și se întreține și
chestiile astea.
Uite pe sau, mă rog, o restricție,
să spun așa,
dar el nu nativ nu face asta el decât
transmite notificarea tu când crezi 9-a
linie specifice automat o dată de
expirare 9 și automat intră din nou pe un
alt flux fluxul standard de alertare,
adică când se apropie 15 zile înainte sau
30 depinde *** setați,
puteți să-l setați cu 2 zile înainte asta
*** o să fie la mâna voastră.
Eu un dicționar unde o să setați când
creați acel document specificat și data
de avertisment, să zic așa, da?
E sfârșit, da?
Păi eu cât înainte recurența se numește
recurența Casă în kilometri sau ore și
recurența înseamnă cu cât înainte trebuie
să te anunț.
Da.
Și la momentul când se finalizează el ori
stăteam.
Odată cumva însă creează o singură listă
de to do practic ți-o transmite pe Mail.
Nu știu,
poate să fie zilnic și verificare se
încadrează în perioadele acelea minime
sau de fiecare dată transmite când atinge
minimul transmite până când cineva intră
pe aplicație și spune că a finalizat acel
task și atunci el dispare din lista.
Cea mai rămas de focuri depinde *** va
Nu.
evolua operațional mai ușor avans alții
nu au vrut așa,
pentru că automat creează și spamului
trimite într-una Mail fiecare dimineață.
Uite cu ce pe listă nefinalizat.
Eu nu cred că e neapărat rău să îi mai dă
peste limandă, nu strică, dar da ochii.
Deci asta e la voi.
Exact deci EO fost bine din experiența
care am prins-o pe la clienți unii au
vrut într-un fel alții într-un fel vă zic
că putem să le facem în ambele feluri.
Bineînțeles,
standard este să pot să accesez o listă
de to din sistem în care văd exact și ce
primesc pe mail în care poți să vizual
din aplicație să fac și chestia asta,
adică nu neapărat să Accesez Mail,
deci nativii el așa funcționează.
Noi am mers mai departe și a afișa cele
ale art.
Da da da da sunt bune și alertele și
normal când le-ai și sistem, da?
Exact da și cam asta așa să vă fac așa o
scurt, nu știu prezentare deasupra,
poți să o să intru și eu mă duc să vă
arăt așa un pic ecran.
Da da da, da.
Ca să îți faci o idee mai mai clar,
dacă mai aveți întrebări sau ai ceva care
nu l-am acoperit din cerințele voastre?
Nu.
Ăăăă da, nu credeți pe mine?
M-ar interesa să știm tot despre mașina
respectivă și utilizatori și dacă s-a
schimbat,
Î.
Sigur.
utilizatorul s-a mutat mașina de la un
șofer la altul când s-a întâmplat asta cu
Exact.
Î.
procesul verbal alocat cu informații
legate de costuri mentenanța când s-a
Da.
făcut revizia,
ce alte reparații când am fost în service
date tot,
adică și istoric și informații despre
Da.
mașină și despre.
Șoferii, documentele asociate,
costurile asociate cam asta.
Camasa camasa asta sunt ce acoperă în
sine modul pentru că e gândit pentru a
Da.
Exact da na nu cred că vine în ceva
extraordinar, Da?
urmări un parc auto a.
Nu până acum,
ce urmează dumneavoastră nu e ceva în
afara acelui element cu partea asta de să
facem acele ă documente de tipărire care
nu le avem în general să țin cu mana fara
carismei ă că se ocupă de lh sau de la un
departament separat noi de AL management,
dar putem să ne gândim la soluții,
Î.
trebuie să vă stau aici,
vedem *** putem să abordăm și subiectul
ăla,
dar s-a apucat prin 2019 a spus și modul
o să fie un modul distinct din caz
maximul Ștefan, așa *** vedeți aici.
Ele se întoarce pe mai multe sub meniuri.
Primul bineînțeles social de vehicul.
Aici o să aveți toate informațiile de
care zicea dumneavoastră aici chiar o să
aveți o multitudine de tablă și
informație.
Ă ă.
Să repar cu puțin și pe partea de
activități.
Sunt însă puteți să întrețineți partea de
seturi de anvelope,
accidentele amenzile care se dau la șofer,
deci asta,
dacă cumva sunteți are documente de care
spuneam în care vin și specifică alte
Î.
documente care vreau să le gestioneze
alocarea de șoferi unde au loc pe fiecare
vehicul șoferul respectiv.
Care este un angajat propriu in sistem.
Da.
Alocare vehicule pe flote dacă vrea să
facă flote, adică să faci o cataloga,
o grupare mașinilor utilajelor.
Da o grupare L.
Da și partea de devize, unde e? De fapt?
Aici trebuie să faceți de fapt
activitățile specifice unui deviz de
reparații în care voiam să-mi spuneți
care sunt elementele și ce sumă de numere
de înmatriculare, *** am zis,
dacă încerci,
dacă urmăriți să zicem sau se schimbă,
aveți foarte multe mașini în leasing sau
în urmează să le preluați voi din leasing,
atunci automat nu mai are același număr
înmatriculare,
dar vreau să știu și ce număr a avut în
trecut și atunci aici pot să spun că
începând din data de până în data de un
număr de înmatriculare pe vehicul ăsta cu
serioasă de șasiu,
iar începând din data de alt numar
Inmatriculare.
Întotdeauna să văd cel mai actual număr
dacă vreau să mă uit în istoric,
Da.
văd și ce alte nume a avut în trecut.
Avem și o interfață de importuri în de
aici,
cumva legat de cheltuieli care ziceți
dumneavoastră în standarde?
Acoperim importul de combustibil de la
lukoil și OMV și de la petrom ă ă.
În general vă pun la dispoziție.
Pe lângă factură,
vă dă și un excel în care sunt
informațiile legate de vehicule și acelea
pot fi importate în sistem în care am dat
a alimentarea kilometri și prețul
valoarea alimentării.
Partea de anvelope,
unde pot să-mi port dacă aveți setările,
*** v-ați încât deja într-un excel puteți
importa sau mai ușor să lucrați în excel
pe partea de seturi de anvelope.
Așa,
un deviz se poate importa din excel să nu
introduc din interfață,
poți să-l și întreținem cumva într-un
excel să îmi port sau ea are și un alt
lucru la care poate fi aplicabil este
dacă vorbesc cu partenerii terți unde
repar sunt până la dispoziție un extras
al import în sistem să mă mai întorc de
mâine dacă au posibilitate sau să import
Da.
documente la fel dacă vă mai ușor să
întreții neamț seturi de documente
într-un exemplu,
se poate ține în excel și important
sistem să nu le introducă de mână de
interfețe și, bineînțeles,
foaia de parcurs care este.
Cea de bază, să zic așa pentru suflet.
Perfect *** v-am zis partea de dicționare
aici o să întrețineți tot ce ține de
partea de fin ă ă ă ă modul în sine și
vehiculele noastre sunt întreținute de la
nivelul de motor,
adică motorizarea care o are el tipul de
ă ă de mi zice.
Vehicul dacă electric,
benzină diesel și așa mai departe ă
producătorul și modelul,
toate astea sunt cumva categoric prin
care el poate fi grupat.
Ă ă ok,
avem parte de acces oriunde putem să
facem piesele, tipuri de piese, piese.
Dacă vreți să urmăriți ă chestii de genul
ăsta?
Ăăăă OK la anvelope,
la fel din fabricație,
modele și așa mai departe.
Stări de vehicul aici,
iarăși o chestie foarte importantă că,
de exemplu,
vreți să urmăriți dacă un vehicul este
neutilizabil,
ca să știți în orice moment în ce stare
să afle, dacă este,
nu știu avariat in service e nu mai poate
fi folosit ceva de genul ca să știți în
orice moment care sunt cele active.
Pe partea de foto unde întrețin flotele,
le creezi ca și grupare șoferii unde s-a
înregistrat și o să creez șoferii pentru
a fi folosiți în suflet.
Tipuri de documente dacă cumva,
nu o să vă punem la dispoziție un set
standard.
După asta vă puteți introduce mai multe
tipuri.
Nici *** am zis dicționar foarte flexibil
pentru voi tipurile de service la.
Acestea sunt master data, de fapt, da?
Mansardei toate de aici *** va plac
gruparea și exact *** ca să știe el să
Datele de bază scumpă.
poată să facă o catalogare și structura
rapoartelor.
La fel de când v-ați camioane și toate
astea poate fi inclusiv tipurile de axe,
dacă sunt pe 8 axe, 4 axe,
2-a axe și așa mai departe,
veți face totuși pe tipul.
Asta se poate face,
mai avem și o noțiune distanță într-un
oraș.
Asta se folosește în general pentru a
crea curse,
adică să zică între nu știu București și
slobozia sunt nush 120 km.
Eu practic creează poți să creezi o cursă
selectezi orașul și nu știe care e
distanța între cele 2 puncte.
Ăăăă nu acum, acum integrată de GPS,
nu prea a mai fost folosită în ultima
vreme,
dar ele au rămas în continuare în
standard aplicații.
Tipuri de taskuri de exemplu,
dacă am taskuri de service, task-uri,
de urmărit, documente că îmi expiră,
nu știu îmi exprim următorul stadiu
documente și practic contact care urmează
să-l facă un flip.
La fel poate fi întreținut de către voi
stări de VIS.
Dacă cumva aveți mai mult decât ce vă
oferim noi?
Scor de anvelope la fel se ricarda că
dacă emiteți și dați carduri de asta de
alimentări sau mai multe carduri care
urmăresc,
Da.
puteți să le creați în sistem și să
alocați arondați la nivel de mașini sau
Îhî.
șoferi.
Ok și tipurile de evenimente care
evenimente poate să fie din acela rutiere
sau consum. De exemplu,
alertele care le folosim pentru diverse
noțiuni din plin.
Ok partea de tutu lis care v-am zis ca
asta e nativ în sistem.
Pe lângă alertele respective,
creează o listă de to do care,
în funcție de când expiră,
el îți arată că în data de trebuie să mă
ocup de următorul element,
este filtrabil pe o altă perioadă în care
el creează acea p în perioada selectată
îți arată ce trebuie să faci.
Ok foaia de parcurs unde poți să o
introduc de mână?
*** am arătat mai devreme sau să le
importe în parte de importuri?
Aici poți să crezi și echipajul,
dacă cumva,
sunt 2 șoferi pe un utilaj pe camion,
de exemplu,
poate fi făcut format un echipaj rute
curse.
Dacă vrea să facă chestii de genul ăsta,
să urmăriți alte rute și curse mai mult,
data asta poate fi folosită pentru,
de exemplu,
dacă aveți costuri pe alte rute sau aveți
ceva centralizat, să zicem,
faci un alt tip de transport,
altele chestia asta costă atâta.
Se poate seta și lucruri de genul ăsta.
Iar o serie departe de rapoarte în care
avem o 6 rapoarte 7 rapoarte standarde.
Partea de service,
unde aici o să aveți operațiile,
seturile de operații și specializările.
Specializările reprezintă partea de
manoperă și ă unde avem forța de lucru cu
omul,
partea de operațiuni dus să setăm ce
elementul să folosim pentru operația,
de exemplu,
schimb de ulei și să îți specificăm ce
articole să folosim și seturile de
operații practică prezintă o grupare a
acestor operații în care să zicem într-un
revizie anuală la revizia anuală,
intră schimbul de ulei.
Tipul de filtru schimbul de.
Cu curele sau ceva și cumva le grupează
pe cele de sus.
Bineînțeles,
există și un import de vehicule în care
să nu introduceți de mână când îl băgați,
puteți dacă luați 10 vehicule odată să le
băgați de mână,
le puteți importa din excel.
Scuze că între întrerupt devizele așa vor
fi împărțite,
Nu e problemă.
defalcat pe mână de lucru și pe pe piese
de schimb. *** ar veni pe comparație sau.
Sunt linii distincte da o să fie linia de
manoperă și până în linia de piese
consumate.
Așa și?
Ă.
Eu am întrebare legată de utilizatorii
acestei aplicații ale gândit pentru
Te rog.
oamenii care gestionează această
activitate pentru flynn manageri avem și
Î.
nu știu anumite,
poate mai puțin e un viu și pentru
Î.
utilizatori, pentru șoferi.
Partea de mobil ziceți, nu?
Nu mă gândesc,
nu știu anumite activități să fie
destinate și pentru șoferi.
Hai să să poată, de exemplu,
dacă iau un laptop sau ceva,
după care poate să intre din camion sau
din mașină sau un dop i se poate pune
drepturi de utilizator în care pentru un
anumit grup de utilizatori nu vede decât
să zicem,
nu știu partea de raport de tot dus,
aceea sau.
Ah OK.
Și unde vreți dumneavoastră sau pe raport,
de exemplu, să aibă acces la un raport?
Adică se poate pune dreptul punctuale
pentru un grup de utilizatori sau un
utilizator. De ce meniu să aibă acces?
Î.
Da pentru că nu m-ar interesa să vadă,
nu știu partea de notificări să ajungă și
la utilizator că el se duce cu mașina să
facă itp ul. De exemplu, da.
P.
Putem să setăm alerte.
Cred că se trimite automat pe adresa de
Mail dacă se poate.
Exact exact se poate face da, deci,
al alertele in sine pot fi setate la
Ochii.
nivel de un grup de e-mail care să facă
ore distribuie la mai mulți oameni sau se
poate seta punctual pentru angajat,
adică mailul propriu,
Nu.
dar recomandarea este să creați grupuri
de mailuri care alocați oamenii și când
Ok da.
se trimit e MAIL pe acel grup locuiesc
toți din mailul respectiv.
Ce.
Gen *** avem noi Sabina pentru toți
conducătorii auto?
Alea da sunt anumite informații,
informări, dar când expiră unite,
N am.
pe interesează doar pe un singur șofer,
nu pe toți ceilalți.
Putem să ne gândim la un mecanism care să
primească șoferul care era odată mașina
respectivă. Dacă a lui se află pe lista,
dar trebuie să ne gândim mecanism.
Asta la asta mă gândeam da și poate și a
numit. Nu știu,
Da.
Ne gândim.
poate câteva câmpuri de aici ar fi
interesate, uite,
interesante pentru utilizatorul final
pentru șofer,
Î.
dar nu vreau să vadă toate costurile pe
toată flota auto sau câte ce fac alții
Am înțeles.
Trebuie să vă gândiți.
sau știi, adică ceva un ecran limitat.
Chestioneze schimbul de anvelope acolo să.
Da anumite activități.
De exemplu, din din din.
Mă gândesc cumva deci vreți la nivel de
de șoferi? Practic,
șoferul să aibă acces doar pe sau, mă rog.
Da pe niște uite,
acțiuni pe niște task-uri pe care le are
Vrem să ne gândim la un.
Oare?
el să schimb anvelopele să facă ITPS.
Uite că.
Îhî.
Nu știu ce altceva cam asta cred.
Astea sunt astea sunt primordiale pentru
că polițele,
Ok.
Î.
cel puțin la mașinile leasing,
se trimite automat de către leasing și eu
S.
Da se ocupă cei de la Turda.
Alea da sînt centralizate dar mai sunt da
și mai e și revizia că el trebuie să se
le trimit, da?
Da.
programeze,
adică și partea asta de mentenanță.
Îhî.
La revizii preventivă da.
Preventivă.
Ă ă.
Câteva sunt câteva acțiuni care țin de
fiecare șofer în parte.
Ok da.
Altele țin de de noi la nivel de flotă,
da?
Am înțeles,
păi dacă voi o să aveți acces complet pe
toată planeta și probabil dacă poate la
alerta de azi ne gândim.
La un mecanism care să primească
notificare pe mail agentul cutare care
șoferul a semnala mașină trebuie să mă
gândesc la un mecanism care să să-i băgăm
Nu.
adresa de e-mail în sistem și când se
apropie de termen sau intră în perioada
Î.
dată să primească pe mail doar pe partea
lui, adică asta ți-a expirat.
Da.
Și bineînțeles să fie și o altă alertă
generală în care trimite toată lista to
către un grup care pe interesează tot.
Ca să facă față.
Da.
Da Astana ă.
Deci,
da fiecare mașină ar trebui să aibe
șoferul alocat o adresă de Mail cu toate
detaliile de utilizator. Oricum,
Un.
Da.
ei au acces în carisma că intră pe
celălalt modul,
adică nu cred că EO problemă din punctul
ăsta de vedere cât deja au acces ca și
Am înțeles.
user pe partea cealaltă.
Ok.
Se poate secționa meniurile,
dar numai că știți care e chestia.
Ăăăă da.
Dacă noi dăm acces să vadă, de exemplu,
raporturile tu tu nu prea poți să-i
restricționezi să vadă și ce alte to do
uri au alți colegi de ai lui,
nu pot să-ți arăt doar punctual
vehiculului.
Din raportul ăla cumva pe o poartă pot
să-i zic să încerc să mă gândesc la un
Da.
mecanism.
Nu avem un standard chestia asta.
Da alertă, da ok OK am înțeles.
Trebuie să ne gândim la un mecanism care
să întreținem adresa lui de e-mail și
cumva s-au asociat la el ca șofer în
sistem.
Îhî.
Și în momentul când mașina aia dacă îl
vede că mașina i-a semnat el ca șofer și
a adus numai valabilă să-i transmită
practic decât din Tudor la punctul lui.
Ne putem gândi la un mecanism de genul
ăsta,
dar dacă el intră în raportul ăsta de
aici aș vrea să-l genereze.
Am înțeles ok, vede tot ok, OK?
Nu am *** să le secționa să vadă,
adică mă gândesc că e posibil să pot e
posibil să nu trebuie să întreb și eu de
ce limitarea?
Da nu știu dacă depinde hai să vedem dacă
se poate, dacă nu nu e ceva men datorii,
Da întreb.
Mulțumesc.
dar.
Întregi și colegii tehnici.
Vedem ce poate face aplicația, Da?
Sigur mai o să mai revină,
dar să mai facă un palat cu o să facă
Da OK.
minute și o să vă zic care punctul să
putem să le acoperim integral prin
dezvoltări sau princiare nativ.
Ă ă OK,
deci la partea de vehicul asta este cumva
interfața condus înregistra și să
întrețineți parte de vechi,
după *** vedeți mai multe informații sunt
împărțite în 4 grupări principale.
Prima este partea de informații generale.
Avem parte de informații de înregistrare.
Parte de informații administrative și
apoi o ultimă parte,
unde avem mai multe taburi când o să fie
cam toate elementele din viața unui
vehicul.
Prima parte aici o să trăiască,
se specifică în mod înmatriculare.
Inițial,
modelul din care face parte el și aici
model avem producătorul,
denumirea și tipul.
Da *** e de exemplu producător Dacia,
denumirea Logan și 3 autoturism.
Sau *** e aici?
Are 9 Mater și autoutilitară.
Un și aici,
la tipul de motor care il selectam.
De exemplu,
același model tip și tip de autoturism
pot să am mai multe modele de motorizare.
Poți să le creezi și să selecteze în care
se încadrează.
Î.
Culoare am fabricat și așa mai departe
chestii ca astea sunt sunt opționale,
să spun așa,
o să fie cele mai importante și care sunt
obligatorii. Sunt seria de motor,
vinul și numărul de înmatriculare.
Bineînțeles, și modelul și tipul de motor.
Astea sunt singurul cu care sunt
obligatoriu să creez un conflict,
restul fiind elemente opționale care vă
poate ajuta în analiza ulterioară.
Starea cumva însă aici,
nu pot să ies pe circuit.
Da ne interesează cam toate da și
furnizori și ani de achiziție și
Păi și așa, dar să zic exact și aici, da?
kilometrii sunt importanți, da?
Și la my aici,
dacă ești să îți specificăm la sursă unde
*** v-am arătat, avem partea mijloc fix,
înseamnă că ești un mijloc fix intern în
care fac o legătură cu modul de mijloc
plus,
Da da.
ceea ce nu e cazul la voi leasing
operațional care trebuie sa specific un
Da.
contract sau închiriat care la fel
trebuie specifică un număr de contract.
Nu.
Dacă îl lasă simplu,
așa înseamnă că este este al meu propriu.
Ă ă partea de client înseamnă că dacă
este închiriată la clientul cutare.
Dacă este de exemplu în leasing
operațional Po trebuie să specific că
s-ar putea să activeze.
Trebuie să specifici numărul de contact,
date de contact și cine este cel care l-a
luat de mână l-a luat,
adică de unde am cumpărat în leasing?
Vehiculul a fost urmărit și chestia asta.
Așa avem partea de kilometri în partea de
kilometri de kilometri.
Suma data curentă dacă e cazul.
Garanții dacă mai există un an și
kilometri am de achiziție că n-a fost
kilometri la achizitie.
Furnizorul nu s-a cumpărat.
Aici EO chestie de consumuri în care pot
să văd consum de vară iarnă,
vară iarnă ă ă în afară și în orașul de
iarnă și va.
Ok.
Înălțimea,
lățimea vehiculului și partea mai avem
parte de informații tehnice de mai multe
informații decât ne permitem partea de
sus aici deja nici la un nivel mult mai
mare. Avem capacitatea greutate, viteză,
tensiunea la baterie. Dacă e cazul,
capacitatea bateriei,
greutatea încărcătură, dacă e cazul.
Capacitate de rezervor puterea lui.
Da.
În partea de un tablou următoare este cam
comparație da cheltuieli.
Cheltuieli.
Mă interesează cea de cheltuieli pe mine.
Exact la partea de cheltuieli,
ca să vrea să vă arăt aici astea,
o să fim în mod automat partea de
documente care le introduceți pe vehicul
ăsta.
Mă rog aici nu sunt completate valori
dacă când creați documentul adăugat și
valoare la aduce aici.
Poate fi introdus direct în ecranul ăsta
sau poate fi introdus din ecranul de
documente de aici?
Depinde unde unde aveți dumneavoastră
nevoie dacă veniți la gestiune documente
și le adăugați și specificați vehicule
sau să apară și aici sau intru de pe
vehicul și dau adaugă și l-au și
interfața asta,
adică permite și într-o parte și
într-alta.
Ok.
Ă ă.
Aici o să vedeți partea de alimentări cu
un vedeți așa vedeți că aveți parte de
Acum.
alimentări,
dar el are o segment specific de
alimentare cu combustibil.
A introdus probabil colegii mei ca test.
Rubrica asta de alimentare de combustibil
este ceva Arătase mai devreme cu importul
acela de alimentări.
Da dacă le importați,
el se duce drept pe vehicul și spune data
alimentării, cantitate și preț unitar.
Ă ă, OK.
Istoric documente exact ce vorbeați mai
devreme că vreți să știți și istoric
documente în sine, dar, de exemplu,
rovinetă data de 21 iulie și aici,
ce tipuri de evenimente expirare document
că expiră pe data.
V-a.
Și avem putem să spunem și kilometri de
inițial kilometri de expirare care
expirare înseamnă cu câțiva kilometri
înainte să ne anunțe.
Dacă el a dat vă zice cu data ă ă,
dacă este tip percea,
puteți să aduceți inclusiv brokerul.
Vedeți aici sunt 2 brokeri. De ce?
Pentru că poate să lase la un broker care
la rândul lui a cumpărat din altă parte.
Atunci puteți să urmăriți până la sursa
finală.
Ok.
Ă ă o rubrică de comentarii și valori,
inclusiv putea să puneți valori ca să
știți cât e valoarea avut bine,
dar e dreptul sau ce au respect sau cască
după caz.
Un număr de document puteți face referire
la alin.
Omule.
P.
Lista de tură care vă povesteam că se
populează,
deci asta se populează la momentul când
se valideaz ă ă ă ă ă,
să zic așa ă ă serviciul sau documentul
care urmează să expire nu se populează.
De exemplu,
aici 2 zile sau 5 zile sau la alertă,
el de fapt o populează momentul când am
validat,
pentru că el creează practic un tot un
viitor.
Ca tot timpul să urmăresc să văd în și în
viitor să văd cam ce ar urma să expire
sau când expiră acel lucru.
Ceea ce acum am arătat o bifă de rezolvat
înseamnă că s-a rezolvat acesta.
Aici și ce vor le autoturismelor,
cartea de identitate,
document solicitat la actori ai timpului.
Da.
Da da da poate și o să fie și cifo ă ă.
Poate să fie și nu știu și alte documente
care poate să expire,
nu neapărat de vehicule,
poate e de la șoferi.
De exemplu,
documentele de șoferi permise atestate
La permis.
auto și dacă are el alte autorizați.
Dacă are el să vă anunță, de exemplu,
că le expiră ca să înștiințați pe ei să
aibă grijă, să și le reînnoiască.
Și-a partea de istoric numere de
înmatriculare cu mască poate întreține
dacă cândva vehicul e în leasing și până
la achiziționarea dumneavoastră,
automat schimbă numărul în mod clar,
nu mai e același.
Ă ă informații de contract, dacă e cazul,
puneți mai multe informații legate de
contractul de leasing aici mai multe
număr contract contract dată început dată
sfârșit,
nu prea să urmărești în conflict restul
de elemente gen contractuale și asta e
cumva în cor carisma.
Ă ă istoric programări,
dacă cumva aveți nevoie să faceți
programări, de exemplu,
către o un service sau serviciul atelier
propriu se pot adăuga aici ca și
programări.
Care veniți și puneți data ora și n-o să
ocupe unde se află starea?
Șoferul care a semnat?
Așa mai departe,
fiecare candidat se adaugă va deschide un
alt ecran.
Da, dacă ați mai văzut care să mă gândesc,
cam știți metodologiile de lucru?
Ok.
Începem să folosim mai intens.
Mai intens am înțeles.
Da.
Super oricum sunt destul de intuitive,
care în general ă mare parte marea
majoritate a ecranelor la salvare,
spune care din câmpul sunt obligatorii și
în general nu te lasa sa salvezi dacă
n-ai mai populate elementele de bază care
ne ce se da aici e ăsta ești și stele și
marchează.
Restul sunt opționale.
Și.
Partea de devize,
unde aici o să vă pară toate devizele
asignate pe vehicul care o să aveți
altfel? Cine s-a ocupat devizul număr,
adică partenerul *** n-a fost trimis data
de deviz dacă este în planul de service
sau nu? Adică, de exemplu,
dacă în planul de service,
adică a fost o mentenanță preventivă care
o aveam programată pentru asta,
el o să fie aici bifat că există ca și
serviciilor specificare plan de service
interne a fost folosit.
Și tipul de serviciu.
Ok piesele dacă e cazul,
cantitățile kilometri care a avut la
momentul când s-a făcut acea reparație
sau schimb valoarea unitară,
valoarea totală că dacă de exemplu am mai
multe piese,
10 nu știu 4 plăcuțe de frână și am o
valoare de 10 blocuri sau să vezi că 40
RON plata.
Foarte tare facturabil este în cazul în
care faceți voi reparații cu datele
proprii către altceva și tu factura
serviciile și piesele folosite.
În cazul în cazul vostru.
Secțiunea de amenzi aici o să puteți să
le adăugați sau să preia din ecranul
specific de amenzi.
În care se specifică ce tip de amendă
este la acea dată în ce locație.
Data primirii amendă dacă cumva este acea
trimise prin poștă valoarea și valuta de
referință.
Seturile de anvelope care pot să le las
inez mașină de grand slam, anvelope,
seturi de vară,
seturi de iarnă și am fi fost demontat în
sensul să știu în tot timpul pe care ST
la momentul de față pe mașină.
Și o locație de stocare.
Dacă aveți mai multe locații,
de exemplu în alte servicii unde le
țineți în chirie sau rate la ei,
să știți unde le găsesc.
Nu este să vă pregătiți acest chin.
Și locație de schimb,
genul de preferat să le schimbați,
poate să difere de cea de stocare.
E starea lui dacă sunt uzate sau noi,
dacă nu a fost folosită niciodată.
Un plan de service unde aici apare planul
de service care urmează a fi făcute,
deci e ca un fel de to do list,
numai că e legat doar de servisare a
vehiculului și aici o să apară toate
planurile server asignate acelui vehicul
ă ă.
Planurile de service în general nu sunt
la nivel de autovehicul,
sunt în general la nivel de modul de
model și motorizare. De ce?
Pentru că 10 mașini identice au aceeași
plan de service,
adică nu diferă între ele,
se întâmplă același lucru,
pot să intervin cumva să schimbi.
Elemente în timp ce fac serviciul
respectiv să zicem că el propune un
aminte 2 RON dacă folosesc alte 2 RON,
dar planul rămâne tot același zicem de
kilometri se fac la toate 10 mașinile
care sunt același model și marcă.
Și cumva sunt legate de marcă și de model?
Și sunt asignate la nivel de vehicul.
Selectăm de aici aici o să apară toate
planurile service ă.
Ă ă ă disponibil pentru acest tip de
vehicul, el o să propunem kilometri.
Următori s-au dat următoare în funcție de
*** a fost setat tipul de serviciu de
plan de service.
Dacă nu pot să vin să modific ă de mână
și pot să zic că la una din mașini mai
vechi un pic, chiar dacă același model,
să zicem că e cu 4 ani mai veche,
nu mai par la 15.000 ha la 10.000,
îl propune la 15.000,
dar avem și schimb manual și pun 10.
Și atunci cumva,
chiar dacă sunt aceleași service urile să
fac distinct în funcție de vehicul.
K.
Șoferii asigurați *** ați zis
dumneavoastră aici avem și adaugă.
Șoferul care pot să-i spun dată de
început,
să zicem că de la întâi până pe 8,
după aia mă duc și dau pe următorul și
tot așa.
Că s așa și aici ai zic că este costache,
niciun punct după 9.
Și las la infinit.
Procesele verbale, le punem la documente,
nu procese verbale de predare primire.
L-aș practica.
Ă.
Acolo documente în plită urmăresc doar
mai mult, cele care expiră,
dacă vreți să adăugați, de exemplu,
un procesor care este făcut de semnat de
Da.
Î.
el și să-l aveți aveți această rubrică de
noapte și atașamente unde pot să atașez
Atașamente nou.
documentul?
Atenție aici pot să atașez documentele,
Â OK.
am acces doar după, de exemplu,
dacă sunt pe calculatorul meu,
nu poate să-l vadă altcineva până la
calculator,
pentru că piciorul îți salvează practic
cu o scurtătură pe folderul pe care ai tu
acel p def.
Adică nu cumva îl pună la dispoziție să-l
vadă oricine ca să vadă oricine?
De ce nu va vedea doar cine îl va încărca?
Cine îl încarcă da, dacă are nevoie,
de exemplu, să intre după un timp,
să se uite să vadă un amic document fără
să mai caute, dar în contextul lui,
adică dacă intri tu după un alt actor,
nu o să pot să îl deschideți.
Apare că există noastră,
poți să-l deschizi.
Nu ca să poată să fie accesibil la toată
lumea.
Asta e un document management system care
un alt modul distinct al aplicației nu
Î.
cred că e cazul la voi pentru cele 50 de
documente care le-au urmărit.
Acum poate să fie de ajuns asta sau dacă
aveți chiar aveți nevoie de acel document
management sistem ca să vorbim ulterior,
da?
Da momentan ok da.
Nu o să le luăm pe rând.
Așa ă ă bun.
Partea de bugete,
în cazul în care să vrea să urmărească un
anumit tip de buget pe alocat pe un
vehicul.
Pe partea de soare de kilometri în care
se vede în fiecare zi câți kilometri
Î.
Ok.
autovehicul și *** a parcurs kilometri.
Aici pe baza asta,
noi avem și integrări cu ă ă Robi în care
se transmite în mod automat 3 elemente,
dar mai mult pentru partea de corp.
Bine că noi am interfața de fapt cu flit
în care din arobs preluăm.
Alimentările care cantitatea alimentată,
consumul realizat de vehicul în zi și
kilometri,
adică traseul făcut o crenshaw Foaia de
parcurs se poate.
Dar doar cu arocs, avem integrare.
Îhî.
Momentan.
Pe partea de alimentare,
combustibil de care vă povesteam mai
devreme evenimentele rutiere.
Amenzile sunt amenzi evenimentelor tale.
Sunt acelea accidente *** ar veni care
avea și 2 casă.
Urmăriți inclusiv dacă aveți dosare de
daună care sunt încă în curs de
clarificare.
Severitate dacă e vinovat nevinovat,
cine a social asigura participantului
cela aici să treceți numele
participantului care a fost în trafic?
Dacă folosești asigurare proprie?
Da dacă mașina a fost reținută,
ca să știu dacă în momentul când bifează
exemplu mașini reținut,
el devine inactiv în sistem ca să știu
*** să folosesc numărul dosar de daună
dată dosar de dauna dată închidere.
Dosarul este finalizat valoare cere
despăgubiri și a spus bine în Casa ta.
În cazul în care va urmări așa da?
În istoric stări,
practic aici a trece prin stările care
le-au vehicul reparație.
Nu știu ă defect sau așa mai departe.
Practic,
ce vedeți aici o să transmit o să
transpună și aici.
Da.
Și avem cine l-a să zicem cine a pus
starea respectivă și de la ce dată până
la ce dată și l-au obligat de comentarii,
de ce?
Dacă vehiculul are accesorii,
se poate adăuga și accesoriile aici.
Accesoriu poate să fie, de exemplu,
la mașini ă ă,
*** îi spunem acele de sus barele acelea
care le folosesc prin portbagajul acela
deasupra asta doar ca să mă rog foto
exemplu,
cand in cap apoi să fie cu totul și cu
totul alte accesorii.
Așa și istoric,
centre de cost ASA reprezintă cumva era
legat de partea de core prezentat centru
de cost a semnat vehicolului dacă e un
anumit departament sau.
Aceasta a fost partea de vehicul să vă
zic așa.
O prezentare mai amplă cumva în ecranul
ăsta,
s sunt afișate sau întreținute cam toate
elementele legate Domnul II.
Dacă aveți întrebări ***?
Uite pentru ce a făcut partidul.
E on a mi-am adus aminte noi avem și
servicii de spălare.
Putem să le punem și pasta spălările auto.
Da la cheltuieli aici să dați, adaugă.
Ah OK.
Specificați descriere spălare auto.
Da mă gândeam ceva gen import *** e cu
combustibilul la fel primim lunar o
Da.
Ă ă.
situație cu fiecare auto și ce spălări a
efectuat în luna respectivă și costuri,
adică e ceva de import.
Părintele important ca document atunci
important ca un document, mă rog,
Da e ceva cu import.
n-am eu să tratez aici.
Putem să le importam ca *** spune ă ca un
document și să-i spunem că documentul se
numește de fapt spălări.
Și aici să importe și să aduci pericol și
descrierea lui,
Îhî.
care posibil spălare cantitatea,
o spălare sau 2 sau câte au fost.
Bucăți și preț și atunci a vă face
valoare.
Ok.
Deci practic le aduceam cheltuieli.
Î.
Să apară aici am cheltuieli eros apare ca
un document în carisma,
Da.
dar cel puțin ne putem folosi doar să
știm că a fost important pentru spălare.
Â OK.
Nu.
Da e destul de clar.
Dacă ești supărat și parte tu *** se
întâmplă,
Noi.
deci practic veți face totul 2 din.
Îhî.
Contează din totdeauna, să zic așa.
Și aici am bifat. Dacă a fost rezolvată,
există și o bifă de văzut în general,
ca să vadă că a luat cina la cunoștință
pe el.
A și tot de aici pot să intru pe ele să
le zică. A fost făcut și dau rezolvă.
Îhî.
Și atunci dispare din acel to do,
deci pot și din ecranul ăsta să practic
Î.
ecranul care tot centralizat toate to do
urile sau pot să intru pe fiecare vechi
facă același *** a fost aici,
de unde vreau să opresc?
Îhî.
Și și poate da utilizatorul rezolvat,
de exemplu înainte pe când își.
Ăăăă da poate să intre, să da,
păi dacă are acces?
Și poate se poate încărca poza de la
talon.
Am situații în când leasing îmi solicită.
Ă ă pe când e cu să încărcați salonul
unde mai exact?
În platformă.
Ă ă ă poți să-l introduc *** v-am zis,
dar totuși are și legat de chestia asta
Deva.
de calculator.
Pot să introduc talonul a ă.
În aceeași notă și atașamente de la
vehicul.
Aici și să zicem că dacă am nevoie
vreodată să-l văd rapid,
pot să dau pe el și să dau să-l
vizualizez,
dar trebuie să fiu să fiu pe calculator
pe care a fost.
Dar nu deci alt atașament și altă poză,
nu poți să atașezi.
Vrem să ne gândim la un mecanism standard,
nu are asta merge doar la nivel de
calculator pe care ai datele respective.
Nu pot să-l accesez cumva dintr-un claud,
să zic așa.
Dar putem să ne gândim dacă vă trebuie
neapărat ne gândim la un mecanism.
O să facem pe lângă ceară.
Și ce ar putea să meargă cumva și am
făcut la un client?
Dacă lucrați remote server,
adică dacă aveți un,
adică toată lumea lucrează pe un server,
să fie toate pe serverul ăla și atunci
automat indiferent ce se conectează pe
carisma are acces la informații.
Da da, da așa da putem lucra așa î.
Asta ar fi o ori că am să lucrați repede
pe server și să nu lucreze pe stație
proprie pe calculator decât să interim o
pe un server la distanță și de acolo să
ruleze carisma și de acolo să creeze și
un repozitoriu de documente 9 și
atașament.
Și indiferent cu ce utilizatori mă
conectez când am luat și atașamente,
Îhî.
am acces pe calea respectivă.
Asta ar fi un oricăror, să zic așa.
Dacă se vrea să fie ceva,
nu știu să zicem că mă conectez fiecare
calculatorului fără să intru pe acel loc
de 4 s-a gândit la un mecanism care va
exista acel modul de document management,
sistem care practic asta face.
El va face un management al documentelor.
Și ăla e un modul de stânga.
Da cred că oricăror andu e suficient de
bun să faci un folder.
Da deci asta ar fi o orcă round p să nu
trăiască să fie implementat document
management SYSTEM.
Notificări către șoferi,
putem să dăm din platformă sau.
Î.
Nu avem opțiunea asta momentan,
adică să dați mesaje între voi ca
utilizatori.
Da exact care să ajungă la toți
utilizatorii.
Ă ă.
Nu avem momentan.
Sau informări sau altceva, nu știu.
Nu.
1 1 Tab D News d up date de ceva de genul
ăsta.
Puteți să folosiți de aici,
ar putea să fie ceva.
Vehicul pe aici pe undeva în top de
proprietăți.
Și tot asta denotă și atașamente că pot
să-i dau nota aici.
Cumva să scriu la suma asta?
Notă.
Și la sumar să încep să descriu în
cuvinte.
Da pot s-o trimit la toți.
Ă nu se trimite,
practic sau putem să ne gândim la un
mecanism care,
dacă îl trecem aici să trimită pe MAIL
Da.
cumva?
Ă ă, dar așa nativ nu are.
Da ok nu.
Ne putem gândi dacă mă gândesc la o
chestie și să vedem dacă putem să facem
să cuprindă și speța asta prin care să
notificați.
Nu știu poate pentru dezvoltări
ulterioare, nu e neapărat acum, da,
Ă ă.
cred că ar fi interesant,
poate și pentru alți clienți.
Sigur nu mi le notez lasagna ta și le le
discut intern și revendicată
Î.
dumneavoastră.
Dacă e cazul să facem sau putem să facem
ceva pe viitor sau.
Împreună cu dumneavoastră,
chiar nu și le analizează intern.
Nu.
Da da, da.
Dar cam asta ar fi așa linii mari,
modul de plat nici nu-i cam ciudat să
acopere el ca să nu intru foarte mult în
toate detaliile.
Vi le-am prezentat cumva mai de sus așa
cumva.
Ă ă ă.
E clar pentru scopul acestei discuții.
Ă ă.
Import.
Când faci minuta,
poți să dai și un fel de cap de tabel cu
Da, adică nu.
Dată.
informațiile relevante pe care le ai.
În vedere,
adică pentru introducerea în să știu la
Ă ă.
*** să le așez dacă ITP.
Nu știu *** facu *** scriu valabilitatea
la roviniete, ca să nu-ți dea eroarea.
Ah.
Asta da la ditamai greșanu când o să
importuri, nu?
Deci.
La in da când faci importurile,
de exemplu,
Da.
din importurile acestea de aici de
documente, de exemplu.
Da.
El în sine are și o metodă de verificare.
Momentul când dumneavoastră oricum o să
vă pună la dispoziție toate capetele de
tabel, adică doamne exteriorul ăsta,
cele care le acceptă sistemul și o să vă
o să vă punem,
Ok.
inclusiv câmpul obligatoriu.
Da deci să zicem că unele vor fi
opționale,
dar cele obligatorii pentru sistem,
adică *** am arătat când am dat salvează,
mi a arătat câmpurile obligatorii.
Acelea vor trebui completate când fac
import în mod obligatoriu ă ă pentru ***
e cazul ăsta,
unde sunt 3 4 coloane în general cam
toate sunt obligatorii unde sunt mai
multe informații, *** e la vehicul.
Astfel descoperim pradă vechi.
Ă ă sau la foaia de parcurs sunt unele
elemente au uitat ce probe sunt unele
elemente care nu sunt obligatorii,
sunt opționale,
care pot fi adăugate alea cumva o să fie
explicate.
Deci *** e de exemplu, a sta pe vehicul,
de exemplu, culoarea nu este obligatoriu,
este opțional.
Înălțimea utilă nu este obligatoriu
furnizori, dacă nu le vor fi marcate,
vreau să vedeți tot.
Toate exemplu *** ar veni cu toate
elementele pe care le poate încărca în
sistem,
dar câmpurile obligatorii vor fi marcate
tot timpul în toate sferele de import.
Și în general pe aici aveți cumva o
explicație,
adică să vă dacă nu vă mai aduceți aminte
*** să faceți?
Și în general majore ecranele au și un
corp de mesaj de eroare.
Când o să vă zică,
ce nu-i convine pentru import?
Ca să-ți faci colecție.
Înțeles, mulțumesc.
Da.
Ok.
Pentru mine e destul de clar,
așa cam ce aveți nevoie,
Da.
*** i-ați cam răspuns la prima.
Primul cu ce ați început eu?
Am încercat să vă prezint așa în linii
mari cam pe ce mi-a zis.
Deci eu zic ca 98 % din ce ați cerut.
Sunt acoperite de modul standardului.
Sunt câteva elemente care pot gusta să le
Da da, da.
confirm *** acele elemente de mail
personalizate pe fiecare șofer pe mașină.
Și chestia cu Mătușa atașamente dacă nu
vrei să folosești celor care au.
Nu cred că e cazul în acest moment ă ă ă.
Nu doar aceste notificări pentru pentru
Cam asta le văd eu ca tine da?
șoferi. Ar fi da?
Da dacă am astea 2-a, le-am identificat,
să zic așa,
cam ce nu acoperă în momentul de față?
În rest sunt cam acoperite toate
Da da.
bineînțeles,
o să vă după să zicem așa *** nu o să vă
dați seama,
de ce mai aveți nevoie în special partea
de rapoarte,
rapoartele ca să introduci în subiect noi
avem câteva rapoarte standard,
nu sunt foarte multe rapoarte aici,
acum vreau să aveți probabil nevoie de
niște rapoarte distincte.
Da și putem să le configurăm?
A.
Ă ă ce aveți în standard,
dar puteți să le faceți voi dacă e în
funcție de elementele care le are, dar,
de exemplu,
dacă sunt niște rapoarte care nu le avem
aici și alți avea dumneavoastră nevoie,
va trebui să reconfigurăm.
Nici avem o parte din care să vă curteze
accidentele,
Ă ă.
să facă niște Alimentări versuri
kilometri,
adică să vă arate alimentările versus
kilometri, a făcut el.
Anvelopele la mașini,
funcție de ce anvelope sunt montate în
sănătate, cheltuielile cu plata?
Samsung aduce tab acela de cheltuieli
afișează aici.
Istoric, vehicul.
Mar de Flotă o listă de to do care
trebuie să generați pe lângă acea acel
ecran este practic un raport.
Pe asta ai cumva pentru partide șantier
dacă există documentele de șofer?
Rapoartele comparative de alimente și
combustibil și consumul asta în general
sunt pentru sunt legate cumva de șantiere,
deci asta încât cazul la voi.
Avem parte de amenzi.
Devizul, dacă cumva faceți voi reparați?
Trebuie să tipăriți devizul de reparație
și foaia de parcurs face un raport
centralizat al foilor de parcurs.
Cam asta este ce acoperim noi ca și
rapoarte standard.
Bine să-l excludeți pe asta cu alimentar
și cu comparative și cu șantierele casă
sunt specifice.
Modului de construcție.
Î.
Ciudat,
dar cumva mai aveți nevoie de alte
rapoarte? Vindecă pe om să le facem,
trebuie să ne gândim ce aveți nevoie cu
datele care există în sistem.
Oricum,
Daniel astea o să fie în etapa ulterioară.
Sigur sexul doar ca să subliniez asta
pentru că mă există de obicei tendința ca
Ă ă.
să credeți că avem cumva un raport care
aduce toate informațiile.
Nu prea e un raport,
mai multe rapoarte care aduc cumva
Am înțeles mai multe, ok da, da e OK.
segmente da care aduc segmente din
informații,
iar dacă vreți ceva suplimentar,
*** să configurăm ulterior din țări?
Da cred că se poate configura ta timp cât
există datele în sistem, adică, da,
Exact exact da în general nu facem un.
nu cred că EO problemă cu rapoartele, da?
Exact da.
Ăăăă OK, deci,
pasul următor ar fi să primim de la
Tallinn oferta.
Î.
Da.
Condusului și un termen ne-ar interesa
cât durează partea de implementare.
Ă ă și după aceea discutăm ulterior să
vedem sa propun și noi să vedem costurile,
Sigur.
să vedem despre ce este vorba și.
Diy.
Și discutăm, da?
Discutăm noi intern,
apoi revin eu către cine cu propunerea
comercial, iar după aceea auzim și vedem.
Da.
Nu putem să mergem mai departe?
Super.
Pentru că.
Mersi mult.
Mulțumesc tuturor pentru participare.
Mulțumim frumos pentru timpul acordat.
Mulțumesc și eu am făcut plăcere.
Mersi vorbim.
Mulțumesc Daniel mersi Sabina Elinii o zi
bună.
A fost plăcerea sarma zi bună să aveți?
Mulțumim zi frumoasa apa.
Zic una.
Da.
Am.